desde que eu comecei o meu site finais
femininas
eu comecei a receber dezenas de emails
diários nos torna as mulheres elas me
escrevem contando suas vidas suas
dúvidas seus problemas e todas as
histórias são únicas
mas eu comecei a perceber que elas não
são tão diferentes assim todas essas
histórias são histórias de independência
independência de um marido dependência
de um salário de um ideal de felicidade
de sonhos de consumo de que o dia que eu
tiver tudo aquilo vou enfim poder ser
feliz é verdade é o seguinte as questões
financeiras elas não dependem de gênero
só que os homens eles vêm a sendo
ensinados a lidar com dinheiro há
séculos
enquanto a gente está começando agora a
ascensão da mulher no mercado de
trabalho começou pra valer mesmo nos
anos 60
no mesmo momento em que a gente teve
direito de ter um cpf e de uma conta no
banco
e a gente começou a ter a
responsabilidade de gerir esse dinheiro
só que ninguém disse pra gente como é
que fazer aquilo
nesse meio tempo mundo mudou hoje as
mulheres elas são responsáveis por 38%
dos domicílios no brasil ea gente está
por trás de 85% das decisões de compra
só que o que eu vejo é que muitas
mulheres continuam que o com dinheiro a
mesma relação que tinham suas bisavós no
finanças femininas a nossa missão em
poder às mulheres através das boas
escolhas feitas com seu dinheiro eu
demorei a perceber isso que a autonomia
da mulher só vai poder acontecer de
verdade no momento em que ela assumiu o
controle dessa do seu dinheiro
ela pode empreender que ela pode comprar
o apartamento dela sem depender de
ninguém que ela pode planejar a
aposentadoria dela pode fazer o que ela
quiser ela pode aprender a guardar
dinheiro aprender a investir e correr
atrás para realizar seus sonhos é boa de
dinheiro você não precisa ser fera de
matemática nenhum excel
não porque o que rege o nosso
a nossa relação com o dinheiro
nossas escolhas dos nossos
comportamentos são as nossas prioridades
a gente paga um preço muito alto por não
querer lidar com o nosso dinheiro que a
dependência tem uma definição que eu amo
muito da casa daqui no que ela diz que a
educação financeira é saber ganhar
dinheiro é saber gastar é saber guardar
ia saber doha
só que a gente vive muito focadas nos
saber gastar e não é atoa gente vive
numa sociedade de consumo e nela as
mulheres são as vítimas da moda beleza
casamento filhos de coração todas elas
focam na mulher o nosso consumo ele está
muito mais ligado a preencher uma
necessidade emocional a você criar um
senso de segurança do que na verdade
algo que você quer propriamente dito
uma bolsa ela não é uma bolsa uma bolsa
desejo não consegue status uma bolsa é
aceitação uma bolsa poder um anel não é
um anel um anel é uma prova de amor
só que quando você faz isso a gente
perde a capacidade de distinguir o que é
a necessidade de que é só desejo é assim
que surgem as dívidas no cartão de
crédito eu quero te tudo e eu quero ter
tudo agora
o que explica esse é o ciência o
hormônio que a gente libera depois de
uma tarde de terapia de compras é a
dopamina tá ligado ao bem estar
é isso mesmo o hormônio que a gente
libera no sexo então quando usar drogas
é o mesmo que a gente sente na hora que
a gente solta o cartão
o problema de medir a nossa felicidade
com o nosso sucesso com base no que a
gente tem é que sempre dá pra ter mais
você nunca vai estar satisfeita sempre
vai ter alguém que tem mais do que você
só que a partir do momento que você
percebe que o seu consumo é mais ligado
ao seu emocional do que as necessidades
reais
você começa a recuperar o seu controle
do seu dinheiro o controle das suas
escolhas
é por isso que eu acredito que realmente
educação financeira para mulheres mudou
o mundo
enquanto o meu salário tenha que gastar
com lazer com compras quanto tem que ir
pro meu aluguel transporte para a saúde
ea verdade é que não tem uma resposta
única uma menina jovem solteira gasta
muito mais com lazer do que uma mãe com
filhos pequenos
só que essa mãe gasta muito mais com
farmácia com saúde do que a menina jovem
isso é natural
só que tem um segredo tem um segredo
básico de como você cuida bem do seu
dinheiro
você não pode gastar mais do que você
ganha
parece óbvio mas isso é um problema em
droid pro gol por boa parte da população
não só brasileira
só que mais do que isso você não pode
gastar tudo o que você ganha
senão você vive no limite você tá sempre
vulnerável qualquer imprevisto vai te
jogar no vermelho
vai virar uma armadilha muito grande eu
montei com o professor da gv o samy dana
uma fórmula de como é que você equilibra
tudo isso que a gente chama de 50 30 20
50 por cento do seu salário tem que
processar cenci ice aquilo que banca o
seu básico do seu padrão de vida é
alimentação e transporte e moradia é o
celular ea internet o básico da tua vida
depois você tem 30 por cento que é para
gastar com supérfluos
porque a vida é feita de prazeres a
gente precisa ter espaço para isso então
compras lazer saídas para jantar viagens
presentes tem gente que gosta de gastar
com o presente porque acha que se é para
o outro da culpa da pesa no bolso igual
e aí por fim em 20 por cento o que é pra
você
é com esse dinheiro que você vai
conseguir
e atrás dos seus sonhos ea beleza dessa
forma é que com ela você consegue saber
quanto você pode gastar com as compras
quanto você pode gastar com você e ainda
assim tem uma gordura tem um espaço pra
você poder guardar poder criar um
patrimônio porque é com esse dinheiro
que você consegue comprar um apartamento
é com esse dinheiro que faz a viagem dos
seus sonhos é com esse dinheiro que você
tem para sua aposentadoria é com esse
dinheiro que você realmente vai atrás
dos seus sonhos
só que pra conseguir isso você vai
precisar de foco você vai precisar de
disciplina autocontrole paciência
persistência
porque quando você sabe exatamente o que
você quer quando você tem suas
prioridades em vista aí você sabe isso
não preciso isso não agora talvez depois
se você não consegue guardar 20% todo
mês começa com cinco
depois sobe para 10 vai aos poucos
comecei a perceber que quando uma pessoa
está vivendo um problema financeiro ela
acha que aquilo não tem solução e que
não dá pra sair daquilo e que se sente
completamente prostrada só que a partir
do momento que ela sumir que está com um
problema e que vai ter que lidar com
aquilo
surge uma força que a gente nem sabe
donde vem que a gente nem sabia que a
gente tinha então eu faço pra vocês um
convite
hoje quando você chegar em casa tirem o
tempo para estudar o seu extrato dos
últimos três meses porque eu sei eu sei
de gente ninguém tem paciência ninguém
consegue anotar os gastos todo dia não é
assim que funciona
só que se você consegue pegar uma hora
por semana e acompanhar seus gastos
encaixar essas três categorias
você vai conseguir ver se seu nome está
ok você está fugindo do controle ea
minha sugestão faça isso hoje à noite
começa agora não deixa para amanhã outra
semana que vem eu descobri que
autocontrole só existe no presente e se
você vai querer recuperar o controle da
sua vida financeira
você vai ter que começar por algum lugar
e não tem melhor data do que hoje
obrigada